Welcome back everyone
it's Charlie
This will be my Bue Beetle post-credits
scene
to explain what's happening
with the character going forward.
There's a whole bunch of stuff
that happened
The ending
James Gunn has talked a lot about what
he's doing with his new DCU movies
and how Blue Beetle
is going to be a part of that.
Some of the other characters
do. Maybe not everybody.
But they will be able to pay off
some of the events of the Post-Credits
scene as opposed to, say, like the Flash
where they had to change a bunch of things
at the ending
Because they had Henry Cavill Superman.
They had Michael Keaton's Batman.
They had Supergirl
doing a whole bunch of different things
that they were never going to pay off.
So they had them remove that
from the flash as opposed to Blue Beetle.
if you're brand new to the channel, be
sure to subscribe to get all the videos.
There's a bunch of big stuff coming up
Ahsoka episodes also premiering next week.
I'll be doing videos for that.
So careful for spoilers
if you have not seen Blue Beetle yet,
but at the end of the movie car parks,
the villain turns
into a version of Brother
I, the iMac project from the comics.
Now it's the Omak project
that turns into Brother
I using the Blue Beetle code
that they derived from the scarab
that allows Victoria
core to basically turn his own suit
from the comics into brother
I like it evolves the same way
that blue Beetle's costume evolves
car parks becomes
like the giga chad version of himself
almost winds up killing blue beetle
in the rest of his family.
Genny cord, Blue beetle
almost dies and is almost separated
from the cause of dark consciousness.
The consciousness of the scarab
itself, played by Becky G,
Earlier in the movie,
his father died and speaks
to him in the afterlife,
saying that it's not his time.
Sort of like this ethereal space.
They don't get too technical on it. It's
not something from the comics.
So this is just something
that the movie introduced for this scene.
he's barely conscious.
He's on the edge of death,
but his brainwaves are able to sync
with Kaiju dogs.
The Blue Beetle scarab,
and they're able
to come back to consciousness in
eventually the Blue Beetle Scarab reboot.
So because it is technically hardware
they're able to overpower car
in the blue beetle scare
because it comes around on him
because they've become this
symbiotic relationship.
She starts to come around
to his line of thinking
and prevents him from killing car parks.
that was a big plot point earlier
in the movie where he tried to prevent
Kaiju dog from killing
a bunch of other people using its powers.
sort of like the Batman thing,
like no actual killing
Car parks winds up sacrificing himself
because he sense what he's become.
He remembers everything that Victoria Cord
did to him when he was younger.
Basically chopping up his body
to experiment on it and create the Omak
project.
essentially they turned him in
to one of the Omak cyborgs
from the Infinite Crisis storyline,
which was created by Batman in the comics.
The satellite Brother
I and Omak eventually evolved on their own
and sort of left Batman's programing and
went rogue and turn into this big villain.
they go back to Palmyra City,
and because Victoria Court has died,
Jenny Cord
becomes the new CEO of the company
and dedicates them to helping the world,
not making weapons anymore.
Very Iron Man, Stark Industries
kind of twist and she and Blue Beetle
start their relationship
and then just start having fun together,
basically implying that they're
going to continue acting as blue Beetle
and she'll be like his bomber, so
to speak, to make a Dragon Ball reference.
there are a lot of anime references
during the movie.
Basically, she has all this cool tech
leftover from Ted Court.
Her father
that will help him be a superhero.
She uses court industries, money
to replace their house
that had burned down in the family
sort of comes back together again
but the father has died
so they kind of mourn him.
The community rallies around them.
So it's a bit of a happy ending
the actual credits are blue and violet
colored for blue beetle colors in court
industries colors
during the first Post-Credits scene,
there's a signal coming from inside
Ted Cordes Blue beetle cape
like his back cape, so to speak.
The song all out of Love Place
because every time they go into the cave,
there's always some 80 song that plays
because that's basically the era
where he disappeared
when Jenny Cord was a little girl
that's why all the tech inside the cave
looks like it's from the eighties and
early nineties because that was the time
where he disappeared.
the signal is coming from him and Ted Kord
There's a bunch of satellite signals
that bounce around like all these systems
activated on the computer in this fuzzy
broadcast from him.
Like a message says Tell my daughter Jenny
court that her father is still alive.
Ted Kord is still alive.
while that scene plays, the camera
zooms in on that third mannequin.
This black with a pillow tied around it.
That's meant to represent Jenny Cord
Eventually.
I think the idea was
when she was younger
and she would visit the cave with Ted Kord
TED Court had always intended for her
to get her own suit
and was going to make it
and put on their mannequin
like the mannequin was meant
to represent her eventual suit
when she grew big enough,
So the idea is that she'll get a super
suit like Ted Cordes blue beetle suit,
not like another scare,
but there was a theory
that she would get a scarab
in a future movie
because they have a bunch of scarabs
at the beginning during the opening
credits, just showing them going
all over the universe.
so it'll be like a man made suit.
I think this also works too,
because she is Jenny Cortazar,
so she'll use tech that he had
basically be the bomber.
Like I said, in the Dragon Ball equation,
this it's not totally clear
who the actor is
that's playing Ted Court In this scene,
they always wind up
recasting that person in the future.
James Gunn DCU movies.
But I think the idea is
they said
that they would bring Jenny Cord back
and we know that Blue Beetle
will come back as a character.
it's not totally clear
if James Gunn intends on paying off
this Ted Kord actor
or if he'll try to explain that
in some other way.
But if he's bringing these characters
back, they had this post-credits scene.
They'll probably try to pay off this
post-credits scene, at least in some way.
The early theory is that he got lost
because he was researching something
about the raids,
like he learned all these details about
how the scarab was alien, quote unquote.
And it's something to do with this
Professor Dan Garrett,
which is also right out of the comics
two in Blue Beetle comic book history.
Dan Garrett's blue Beetle suit is right
here.
Next to Ted Cordes blue beetle suit.
So the idea is that Dan
Garrett was a character inside the movie.
They reference him at the very beginning
in the opening credits
What probably wound up happening
is that he disappeared when he found out
about the reach,
and it sounds like he also hid the scarab,
which Victoria Kord was looking for
at the beginning of the movie.
So it's not necessarily
a post-credits scene all about the reach.
That was one of my early theories too,
is that they would tease
the coming of the rich because that's like
the whole big bad of the entire Blue
Beetle comic book storyline
But what they can do in
James Gunn's future DCU movies
because they're all meant
to be interconnected.
And we know that Green Lantern is coming.
Nathan Fillion is going to be a version
of Guy Gardner in Superman Legacy.
We know they're going to do the Booster
Gold TV show,
and Blue Beetle is supposed to crossover
onto that.
They can pay off all this rich stuff,
this storyline
during some of those upcoming movies.
the second Post-Credits
scene is just a longer version of that
animated Latin American TV show El Chapo
in Colorado that they use
to distract the court industrys guards
Earlier in the movie,
when they were using his uncle's machine.
the actual clip in the Post-Credits scene
introduces the characters comic powers,
like within the context of the TV show
itself, the Jordanian nation,
which is in Spanish,
explains to the public
how the chopper scene is more agile
than a turtle.
Stronger
than a mouse, nobler than a lesson.
For those that grew up in Latin
American countries.
It's meant to be
this hilarious callback to a TV show
they all watched during childhood.
The director said that for everybody
else, though,
like if you didn't grow up
in a Latin American country,
it was meant to be this funny
slapstick TV show,
like just a funny moment paying off
the funny moment from earlier in the movie
the actual character El Chapo is a
character created by Robert Gomez Bolanos,
this legendary writer, actor director
that had a comedy show in the 1970s named
Chess Burrito.
Chaplin is a superhero
that appeared multiple times on that show.
every time someone needed him,
he would show up help
only to cause more trouble
due to his clumsiness,
which they show in the Post-Credits scene
So part of the idea
here is also paying homage
to the superhero TV show from the 1970s.
This started before.
So like the Incredible
Hulk TV show, like American superhero
TV shows for Marvel and DC,
the actual character wound up getting
its own spinoff TV show after that.
That ran for like eight seasons
in 260 episodes.
It became this really highly popular
character within Latin American culture.
at the end of the clip, you hear George
Lopez's voice and he's kicking
like a giant machine saying, That's sexy.
It's probably dialog
taken from earlier in the movie
when he was distracting the guards
with his machine
and had to kick it
a bunch of times to get it to work.
there's a lot of Latin American culture
sprinkled into the movie.
Like earlier in the movie,
the grandmother is watching
a bunch of telenovelas
and a bunch of Hispanic TV shows
So a lot of people have asked what's
going to happen to Blue Beetle after this?
I think short term
he's going to show up on things
like the Booster Gold TV show crossover.
Then maybe we'll see some crossovers
with the Peacemaker character
because he actually did crossover
with Peacemaker in the comics.
in It feels like those two characters
would just work well together
in brief episodes
or part of a movie or something like that.
the actor.
Trillo did say that
Batman was one of his all time
favorite characters,
and he wanted a crossover with Batman.
In the future,
they're introducing the new DCU version
of Batman in Brave in the Bold,
but that won't be for a couple more years,
so he might eventually crossover
with the other Justice League characters.
I think that's part of the idea
I'm a sucker for Batman.
I know everyone says Batman.
I also love Batman.
I like Harley Quinn.
I like the stuff that they do,
especially in the cartoons.
Yeah. Yeah.
DC Animations.
The animated Batman movies
are some of my favorite.
And I like Doctor Fate.
He's. He's also he's also cool.
Young Justice.
That's kind of where I've seen
most of my DC content.
They did say that they set things up
for a sequel, like that's what the Ted
Kord scene is specifically meant to do
in the Post-Credits scene for a sequel.
But I don't think that they will do Blue
Beetle two.
Even if the box office does well,
what they'll do
is they'll just fold all these characters
into upcoming DC projects
if you bought it, any other Easter eggs,
the references in the Post-Credits
scene, just write them below.
In the comics we have questions
about the futures of the characters.
I'll try to address those in the comments.
My Full Breakdown and Easter Eggs video
we'll post the next day or so.
And big reminder the Ahoka episodes
are now starting a day early
and they're going to air Tuesday night
Pacific Time.
make sure to enable alerts for my channel
so you don't miss any of that stuff.
Click here
for that full blue beetle breakdown.
Easter eggs already the link.
As soon as I post that video and click
here to learn about Daredevil Born again.
That first look was Spider-Man
Punisher coming back in a whole bunch
of Marvel Netflix characters.
Thank you so much for watching.
Everyone stay safe
and I'll see you guys in the next one!